hello everyone and welcome back to Ted
connects if you're for them if you're
joining us for the first time we've been
bringing you interviews all week with
some of the world's greatest minds to
help us make sense of this unprecedented
moment that we're living in I'm Whitney
Pennington Rogers Ted's current affairs
curator and one of your hosts this week
thousands of you have tuned in to these
live events each day and hundreds of
thousands more have watched these
interviews after the fact we've really
loved seeing your questions they add so
much to these conversations so please
keep them coming and in a few minutes
I'm going to disappear to work with our
team behind the scenes to monitor our
facebook feed where you can leave some
of your questions I'll work to figure
out which ones are the ones that we can
bring back to our our guests and I will
ask as many of them as I can during the
live interview today we're going to be
touching on a subject that I think is
top of mind for a lot of people so I'd
like to turn things over to the head of
Ted Chris Anderson who will introduce
today's guests like hi Chris how's it
going today that's to see if I can
Whitney it's going pretty good here
amazing days that's good that's great we
have sunshine here in in the Northeast
which is nice so look I I I'm excited to
introduce this guest cuz I've known
that's Beckley for a long time I count
him as a friend
he's a man who has really devoted his
life to the most profound questions
about public health vaccines are
extraordinary they save millions of
lives the quest for a corona virus
vaccine is I think the biggest single
question that the world faces now if
we're going to get out of this so it's
it's just a delight to welcome dr. Seth
but Lee 2:10 connects come on and Seth
good good to see you
err Chris and and delighted to be with
you and and all of Ted community
well telecon on Tuesday bill gates was
here and he mentioned that your
organization Gavi is is really at the
heart of the quest for a vaccine so tell
us a bit what what is Gavi so Chris
thank you for that um what's interesting
is that twenty years ago we just
celebrated our 20th anniversary but
there were all these powerful new
vaccines that were being used in wealthy
countries and the challenges they
weren't getting to the places that they
could make the most difference the
developing world so Gavi was formed as
an alliance WH o the World Bank the
Gates Foundation UNICEF all working
together to try to bring these vaccines
developing world and it's been very
successful we've launched four hundred
and thirty three new vaccines in the
most difficult countries in the world
and the Somalia's and Yemen's and DRC s
and Nigeria's but we've also set up
emergency stockpiles for outbreak based
vaccines so if there's an outbreak
anywhere in the world of yellow fever or
things like cholera or meningitis and
now Ebola we have vaccines that are
available to do that and the last thing
we are trying to do is build the health
systems out to be able to deliver these
vaccines but also to make sure that we
can pay attention to new diseases that
pop up in different parts of the world
and just give us a sense of the scale of
this how many vaccines you distribute in
a given year and how many lives do you
believe that that may be save it so I
mean let me give you a macro number
we've immunized more than seven hundred
and sixty million additional children
sorry billion additional children
million seven hundred sixty million
additional children and evented more
than thirteen million deaths we on an
average year we give about a half a
billion doses because we started out
with six diseases but now we vaccinate
against 18 different diseases
incredible and amidst all the bad news
that's happening it's kind of amazing
that this this intervention an ER just
phase consent so many lives I mean help
us understand what what a vaccine is so
the original idea the word vaccine comes
from vaca or cow and the observation
made in the 1700s that milkmaids had
beautiful skin whereas everybody else
had pock marks from having gotten over
smallpox and the and the concept was
that she was getting infected with a
zoonosis that is with
naturally-occurring cow pox not smallpox
that then protected against smallpox and
it was tested in those days could you
artificially do that they'd of course
didn't understand virology they didn't
understand any of those issues but what
a vaccine is is something that you give
to artificially stimulate the immune
system hopefully to not make you sick
but then later on when the body comes in
contact with the real disease it thinks
it's already seen it and it is able to
fight it off without making the person 6
dick I mean it's kind of a miraculous
thing to me that they worked that way
that some you know that your body is
always there looking for these threads
and a vaccine it I guess the body
perceives it as a threat and therefore
arms itself against that threat right
and then and that that's what gives the
protection and so how if but it's not
why people have some people are sort of
irrationally I will say irrationally
scared of vaccines and feel that they
may be dangerous because they are kind
of a threat that you're putting into
your body in a very subtle way well of
course when this first started there
were two ways to make vaccines you could
grind them up and inject them so-called
whole killed vaccine so you took
organisms and you got an immune response
and sometimes those organisms even
though they were dead gave you are
pretty whopping immune response your
arms were sore you got fevers then we
moved to these weekend live viruses and
frankly those are the best vaccines
that's what easels is that's what yellow
fever is these are weakened viruses they
don't
give you disease but because they look
like the natural viruses your body gets
protection and frankly you know you get
protection for your whole life today
because people are worried about
side-effects we've begun to use
molecular biology and use little bits of
it and and therefore you know it's moved
forward but the reason people are mostly
scared is because frankly vaccines have
been so successful you don't expect if
you have a child or two children that
those children are going to die of these
diseases unlike in the past when you
know three or four out of your five or
six or seven kids would die so today
people think well gee these diseases
aren't around they're not that bad and
by the way if I'm injecting these things
maybe they're not organic maybe it'll
make my child cry maybe it'll make them
sick and I don't need to do it and and
that's the challenge you don't want to
scare people to death on how bad these
diseases can be but at the same time you
want them to understand that these
diseases are serious and can cause
really bad disease and sequela so
yesterday you issued a really powerful
call for this sort of massive
coordinated global response to tackle
the you know the search for a corona
virus vaccine we're going to come to
that in a bit because I think that's a
very exciting topic but I think we need
some more background first so I just I
wanna go back five years to when you
stood on the Ted stage and you held up
who candidate Ebola vaccines this was
just a few months after Ebola had been
terrifying the world you said you know
what look you know it was basically
amazing how quickly those vaccines had
been developed
what what happened to them so it's a
great question and let me tell a little
bit of the story but at the end there
were two vaccines one it turned out
couldn't finish its testing because the
epidemic died down the other one was
fully tested it had a hundred percent
efficacy we then went on to work with
manufacturers to produce that vaccine at
least temporarily in an investigational
form just in case there were more
outbreaks there were and
those are the vaccine doses that we've
used in the DRC and the last two
outbreaks 280,000 people have been
vaccinated with this experimental
vaccine and today there is a licensed
vaccine and we are now procuring a
stockpile global stockpile of a half a
million doses but let me just say let me
just say Cristo the reason what's
interesting is that the reason they came
so quickly at that moment is after
September 11th there was concern in the
US about bioterrorism remember there
were anthrax attacks and so what
happened was there was a list of agents
and Ebola for a short time was on that
list of agents so people started making
vaccines and then later on they decided
that I was not necessarily a good
bioterrorism agents so they they dropped
that off the list but in the freezers
were vaccines that had been started and
they were dusted off and that's why we
could move so quickly in that moment yet
how long was it from that moment on the
Ted stage with the candidate vaccine to
actual deployment so what happened was
the epidemic began to go down the
clinical trial I told you about was done
it was a heroic clinical trial done by
w-h-o and it showed that it had these
results that epidemic then stopped we
didn't know if there were going to be
more epidemics it took another number of
years for the to finish the work on the
vaccine to make sure it was pure to
figure out how to manufacture it at
scale it's during that period we put
vaccine you know away and had it
available in case there were other
outbreaks and it turned out there were
three outbreaks 101 went away quickly
but there were two I was there on day 13
of the second outbreak we injected the
vaccine cases went up and they went down
and controlled it and then this DRC
North kilo outbreak which really was
terrible because it was in a war zone
and that's the one where we've been not
only vaccinating in DRC but in
surrounding countries by the way that is
now I believe day 38 or 39 out of the 42
necessary to say it's over we hope it is
and that would be again an enormous
example of what vaccines can do even in
a very difficult setting
and yet in one way says it's kind of
shocking that the outbreak that happened
at the start of 2015 and of 2014 that it
happened at all because the world like
the world is known about Ebola for a
long time the it was sequenced and so
forth a vaccine could have been
developed and got ready for a possible
outbreak why didn't that happen well I
mean there had been 26 outbreaks before
but each one of them was small couple of
hundred people or a couple of dozen
people in the poorest African countries
in the world there was no market for it
people didn't know how to test it
because they would just pop up and then
go away and so even though it was
obviously a disease that potentially
could spread it had never really spread
before of course in West Africa they
didn't have a good surveillance system
it spread for three months before people
identified that it was Ebola and by that
time it was too late it if spread and so
you know what's important about that
lesson is that then caused a huge
disruption across Africa across the
world because cases went to other places
and you know the challenge then was and
the reason we had a step in was because
there still was no market so the GAVI
Board said we will put out 390 million
dollars we'll put it out there and tell
companies we're open for business will
create a market will buy the vaccine and
that led to companies be willing to
finish the investment to get us to where
we are today right right so I mean it's
a real paradox right in a way that the
very thing that makes vaccine so
extraordinary that they are once they
develop they are so cheap to administer
you know for a few dollars I guess you
could you can administer this dose that
will save someone maybe a lifetime of
illness or say save the lives and yet so
much of medical research and invention
and development is done by companies who
need to see it like a revenue stream and
so they don't see it from from those
tiny little cheap things that might save
a lot of lives and so it's a real market
failure that in this circumstance now we
that's one of the things I guess you're
thinking hard about how enough do we get
round and avoid that market failure
for playing the response this time well
first of all one of the reasons Bill
Gates likes vaccines is in a sense it's
a little bit like software creation you
put a lot of money and effort into
creating it but once you've got it you
can produce a pretty cheaply and use it
in different places around the world I
don't want to beat up the pharmaceutical
industry here because they were heroic
in Ebola but I think realistically they
are for-profit entities and they have to
say to their shareholders you know
somebody's going to pay for this or
we're going to do it as a charitable
thing and if we do it as a terrible
thing they can't keep doing it since
then there is a new initiative called
Teti the Coalition for epidemic
preparedness and innovation it was set
up at Davos a few years ago and its
purpose is to try to make vaccines for
the list of diseases that aren't yet
known epidemics but that can potentially
be there and the idea would be that
using public sector money to get us
prepared of course they've jumped in on
this coronaviruses as well last thing is
of course I'm not worried about on the
coronavirus stage that that this is a
problem with not having a market one of
the challenges here is that there may be
too big a market for this and therefore
how do we make sure there's access for
developing countries
all right so talk about this virus stuff
how is it different from Ebola how
challenging is it to create a vaccine
for it so what's interesting about
coronaviruses is that they are animal
viruses probably primarily in bats they
jump into other animals sometimes and
then they jump into men so this is
shouldn't have been a surprise this is
the third Barona virus that is that has
jumped into human we have SARS in early
2002 we had mayor's you know a number of
years later and now we have this virus
what's interesting is there is a
database that shows there are 30,000
some odd isolated corona viruses in
animals and one of the things that
people tried to do is say the way these
corona viruses work is they have a spike
on them they're called Corona because
they look like the Sun that spike is
where it attaches to a certain receptor
in people's lungs and so somebody said
well maybe you can begin to look at
those spikes and see if they're similar
to the human
receptors and maybe we can predict but
the problem is people don't invest in in
those types of research and and of
course I think from given it's an
evolutionary certainty we're going to
see this that we should be but one other
point about this is coronaviruses jumped
in to humans in ancient history as well
and so we have now about a third to a
quarter of the common cold viruses are
actually corona viruses and what's
interesting about those is they don't
make you deathly ill like these but we
also don't have long-term immunity to
them so you can get reinfected with
these viruses after you know ten months
a year and so that does raise an issue
on vaccinology because you won of course
ideally have lifetime immunity that the
reason why we get reinfected is because
the virus mutates slightly and so it
escapes the antibodies that might in
this case not in this case so in in flu
that's what happens the viruses were
always mutating in HIV the reason we
don't have a vaccine is because they're
all mutating in this case the immune
response seems to get weaker and go away
and people get reinfected with the same
viruses now that is not that is
potentially a solvable problem using
vaccinology and many different
techniques but the point is we just
can't assume and some people now are
talking about herd immunity as a way to
deal with this virus and the idea there
is if you could get enough people
infected you know forget for a moment
that a lot of people are going to die
and be miserable while that happens but
the idea is then you get a certain level
immunity in the community and then the
disease will go away well that is only
true if you get long-term immunity if
you don't then you could go through all
of that horrible experience have all
those deaths and then not have the
protection you need to protect against
this disease okay so in a way the quest
we're looking for is a vaccine that will
work for the long-term and I mean I I
mean I guess any any vaccine that works
at all will be a huge gift but it could
well be one that we have to retake every
year or something like that that is
certainly possible of course that we
have to remember though that SARS and
Mayor's both had even higher mortality
than this virus does and they give a
much more profound immune response so it
may be that they
act more you know differently than the
common cold virus is a challenge of
course is is that you know we haven't
had the opportunity to study these over
a long time and this new disease is
three and a half months we've had it
more science has been done for this
disease in this short period of time but
we don't understand fully the
epidemiology of the virus the immune
response
what's protective which is the best
animal model all of that is being worked
on by science but and at breast net you
know breakneck pace but a lot to learn
so to talk about how how you know the
the medical and the research community
responded because you know the Chinese
authorities I guess we heard it
yesterday only found out about this it's
sometime in December already early in
January I mean I think the virus they
think the virus started in November they
found about it in December by early
January they had already released a
sequence of the virus to the world and
now here we are and I think I think I
saw that more than 40 companies are
already claiming handed it vaccines what
does it mean to have a candidate vaccine
like I have of companies tested this
already against animals or something or
are they just looking at a computer
model where they go that should work
what an interesting question you ask
there so first of all China was heroic
on this they did post the genetic
sequence of it today we have companies
that can sit down with a computer and
from that genetic sequence make what is
a candidate vaccine now a candidate
vaccine obviously means it's not a
licensed product it's something that
somebody wants to work on but you're
right you have to have the right
nomenclature because candidate can mean
I'm working on something it's in my head
I'm just doing a little work on it I've
got something in a vial
I'm beginning to do testing on it and so
what we saw in that case was a company
called moderna that was the first
vaccine that went into humans
it's a messenger RNA they system I
actually visited the company not in this
outbreak but before because the
technology is interesting and what they
were able to do is in 42 days make a
candidate vaccine from the genetic
sequence they didn't need the organism
that now is in clinical testing now they
is no licensed mrna vaccine so we're
gonna have to figure out you know is it
safe is it doesn't work in all different
age groups how are we going to scale it
up all that but there are many others
who are using conventional vaccinology
though an example would be the French
are working on a measles based vaccine
so the idea is to put the spike protein
in the measles vector and it takes a
little bit longer to do that work but
once you have that done of course we
know how to make measles vaccine we've
met you know we make hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
doses and provide it to the whole world
so if you know that was to work that
might be easier to scale up so I think
what we want in the race is to have
multiple different vaccines moving
forward you know we don't want one or
two we don't want a hundred in the late
stages because it's expensive and hard
to do but we want to have diversity of
science approaches going forward which
of the other candidates out there are
you excited by or at least intrigued by
well for me the critical issue here is
going to be we have to optimize for
speed and so that means as I said you
know having examples of all the
different new technologies that could
potentially work as well as conventional
doses moving forward at the same time so
what you're going to want to do is have
this bubble up and it's not just
companies it's or big companies it's
also biotech companies it's also
academic researchers that are working on
this you want all of those to bubble up
then you want to be able to you know
look at what's the most promising and
that will depend upon animal results
it'll depend upon being able to produce
those vaccines have a pathway and
eventually you will want to put those
into human clinical trials that requires
a certain amount of safety work you can
try to accelerate that but then you need
to say okay we need to know how do we
need one dose do we need multiple doses
do we need you know 50 micrograms 100
150 do we need a chemical stimulant we
call an adjuvant given that this disease
has you know it's it's it's it's big you
know problems and outcomes are in the
elderly we might need to put some
stimulants and to make it a more potent
immune response so all of that work has
to go and that's what the clinical
testing is eventually you say aha here's
the vaccine we're going to use now you
test it in an efficacy trial and that is
to see does it work and and at that
point you then have a vaccine that you
know works but there is a stage after
that and that stage is you've got a you
know workout the manufacturing have it
all worked out so that you know the
regulator's know that you can really
make this and that it's cure it doesn't
have any any any problems with it and
during that period and that's what we
did in Ebola we were able to use those
vaccines to help in outbreaks you know
under a clinical trial protocol while
monitoring them and learning so there's
a lot of steps there and that's and it's
complicated and I've shortened I
summarized that summarize the steps that
they basically need to go through i had
like probably an animal and animal test
and then for example moderna moderna did
you know they went into humans at the
same time they're doing animal testing
um we don't have a perfect animal model
but normally it takes 10 to 15 years to
do this
and that's the compression you're trying
to do here so the challenge is we can
compress all those different clinical
trials the basic the way you think about
it is preclinical studies animals
understanding it purity you know
reproducibility then you move into human
studies you start off with a small
number of healthy people you then work
on the dosing how much how often then
you move into people at risk for the
disease that might be in this case the
elderly or people with other conditions
and then eventually you do an efficacy
trial now one of the cool new things we
can do today is something called
adaptive trial design so rather than do
these you know sequentially which you
can begin to do is enroll people and
then as you get the data you need you
can just begin to bring in the next set
of groups and by doing that you can
speed it up dramatically right when you
say enroll people you mean roll people
who have their eyes wide open it they
have informed consent I think that's the
term absolutely and they're willing to I
guess take the risk this isn't a fully
tested vaccine but but it may well be
efficacious and
so that obviously can help a lot is that
that that's that's crucial to this right
absolutely they are the unsung heroes of
vaccinology because people go out they
volunteer to take a substance
particularly early on that don't know
how it's going to react is it going to
make the disease worse is it gonna make
it better is it going to protect them as
if not is it going to make them sick so
you try to predict that if you can with
animals but people do do that and the
informed consent says not only you may
have these side effects of these
problems but also this vaccine may not
work and so you know it's important for
people to understand that because you
don't want people to go and put
themselves at high risk saying oh gee I
had a vaccine and so I'm protected we
don't know that until we get to the
efficacy stage of trials but Cynthia
been putting together all those all
those dots like what I've heard most
people say is that it is likely to take
at least 18 months before the world will
have a vaccine available at at any kind
of scale is that timeline right and can
the world remotely afford 18 months on
this well I think you know I've given
you many questions I could raise lots
more questions so part of its going to
be luck
how easy is this particular candidate
vaccine going to be you know how lucky
will be in getting a good immune
response which approaches will work will
they be scalable so I think there's lots
of questions there the world will do
everything they can to squeeze it down
but I think that's the timeline we're
talking about and remember it's 10 to 15
years usually in the case of Ebola we
did it in five years to a licensed
product in this case we are hoping to
squeeze it down dramatically but you
know there are many things we're gonna
have to go through and it's and it's
really about making sure that vaccine
works and and it is safe for use in what
ultimately may be billions of people
Whitney hi so we have lots of questions
coming in Seth one of them is kind of
related to this is you know a lot of us
right now are isolating and we're not
building our exposure to this virus so
how will that affect us in the long term
will this make us vulnerable to the
virus until that
scene is available so that's a great
question and as you know we don't fully
understand the epidemiology of this
virus but there is some sense that there
may be asymptomatic s-- do they get
immune protection are they afterwards
you know resistant to infection we don't
know that but we do know that people do
get sick including young people and that
sickness can be quite severe obviously a
lot of it is mild but some of it's quite
severe and then it gets more severe in
the elderly so I wouldn't recommend that
anybody go out and intentionally try to
get exposed to this virus now the whole
idea of having isolation now is to try
to get got the chains of transmission
protect health workers and hospitals
with the idea being that if you can
suppress it enough and Bill talked about
this in his talk and and later on have
testing available you might be able to
go back to somewhat of a normal life and
then watch for reintroduction of this
virus of course you know at the end of
the day we will probably need a vaccine
to be able to completely control that
but the experiments going on in China
you know Japan has done an amazing job
of controlling this with slightly less
severe interventions we've seen in in
Korea similar things so you know the
hope would be that if we take it
seriously we actually damp down the
exposures and stop this epidemic now
you'll be able to remove to some form of
normalcy and and we also may have drugs
and drugs will change the dynamics as
well as people will then know that they
are able to get treatment as well great
I'll be back later with other questions
I'm seeing thanks weeks thanks everyone
watching keep those questions coming
come assess it this timeline like I've
I've been puzzled about this because I
get that there are so many things that
you have to have to be checked out but
it's still I I worry that the rules are
not adapting rapidly enough for the
scale of the emergency I mean my my
analogy you know would be you're going
back your lives and and suddenly there's
this emergency you see that there's this
enemy force approaching you from the
rise and coming
direction you don't in that circumstance
and a week you know trying to test all
your guns and make sure they're
operating absolutely safely and in the
right way you know you you you galvanize
and you and you do take some additional
risk for the sake of avoiding the bigger
risk is is that thinking prevalent right
now are there people trying to make
those kinds of trade-offs how should we
think about that or do you really
believe that the community is
galvanizing and moving forward as fast
as it humanly can and and appropriately
balancing the two risks I think we're
seeing heroics in moving forward here I
think you know obviously you're right
and the reason we talk about going from
10 to 15 years down to something like 18
months is about squeezing those steps as
much as possible the regulators in the
Ebola experience we're really fabulous
they worked with us and tried to keep
any bureaucratic delays down to you know
the smallest amount possible and I and I
think that's what's going to be
important here is we have to look at
every single step and say is it critical
but you do need to answer a lot of these
questions for example if you have a
vaccine that's how that works in healthy
people it's very well may not give an
immune response in the elderly we may
need to you know change that vaccine to
make it work there we you know it may
not work in young children so you need a
certain amount of the studies done of
course if you work in areas that have
big outbreaks you're able to also enroll
more quickly and follow people more
quickly and that's one of the reason
we'll have to think about this globally
because we don't know in 12 to 18 months
when or even 6 to 18 months if we're
really lucky the air the epidemic will
be raging and where we want to do the
the clinical trials we should be
prepared to do them wherever in the
world it's possible and also do some in
different types of countries developing
countries manage your immune responses
then in wealthy countries
then what's alarms me a bit is that on
the models I've looked at with the
possible exception of what what happened
in China and Japan what you couldn't buy
by distancing we can we can bend the
curve
can reduce infection but as soon as you
go back to normal there's this the huge
risk of a massive research in it until
the vaccine comes along it feels like
your choices are one but I've kind of
recklessly exposed the whole population
to the bug and develop some kind of herd
immunity or try and do this scary dance
of really cramping down on the economy
and all the risks that are associated
with that and I'm risking you know if
you if you if you lift the lid on that
risking these sort of really dangerous
second surges so I mean it's not the
right way to think about it there's
there's a scenario where until this
happens and it might if it's 18 months
that's an incredibly long time for the
world to be on that sort of dangerous
gary dance well I think you know the
issue here is that is a little bit the
way to think of it but the experiments
going on now China is now releasing its
controls and we will see what happens
there we'll see where they have to clamp
back down and what's going to happen and
we'll get a good idea of what that's
like right now in many countries we're
still in the upscale period when we're
seeing lots of cases and so we have to
break that transmission first before we
can have that conversation I'm the first
person that would like a vaccine to
occur quicker and of course you know my
job is to you know over you know
under-promise and over-deliver not the
other way around and I think that we
have to be careful not to think about oh
we can just have a vaccine in a couple
of months it may be that we're lucky it
may be that it's easy to do it may be
the first few candidates will show
promise we get efficacy we can scale
those up for at least some limited use
while it's being worked out but but a
lot of things have to fall in place for
that to happen and that's why we want to
have an organized global effort to
absolutely incentivize the best possible
chance for that to happen in the fastest
way there's some kind of debate out
there about whether there might be way
way more cases mild cases basically zero
symptom cases of coronavirus out there
that have may have granted more people
immunity than we know is that is that
digestion more cases a much lower
fatality rate than we know because so
many of the cases invisible
you know Mayor Bloomberg used to have a
saying that I loved he said and god we
trust' everybody else bring data and I
think the answer here is we haven't done
enough testing to know and we started
out with PCR tests to look for virus and
therefore if you had recovered didn't
have the virus anymore we weren't able
to pick it up now there are beginning to
be anybody test but look to see if
you've been exposed and you know don't
have the virus now but have an immune
response to it once we have those tests
operating at scale we'll be able to
understand what the epidemiology is and
what's happening and then we'll be in a
much better place to understand how this
is playing out also I mean even the
question we don't see a lot of cases and
children is that because the children
get infected but they don't get symptoms
and therefore they might be potential
spreaders or is it because those
children you know don't get it at all
to tell us about this call that you
issued yesterday I mean you've said that
scientists behaving heroically but
you've called for something for
something more here from both scientists
companies governments tell us tell us
what your call is so first of all I
believe that given the situation here
this is not that the time to just let
the normal system work as we've talked
about I think we have to think about
vaccines as a global public good and and
what that means is that initially it
ought to be public sector financed
obviously if others want to contribute
resources
I believe they you know it should they
fine but we want to make sure the best
approaches come and it doesn't matter
where they come from in the world we
want to make sure if the best approach
is in China or Japan or in South Korea
or in the u.s. wherever it comes from
whatever company has the ideas get them
on the table then we want a process to
say realistically you know how are these
being compared how do we decide which
ones are most likely to succeed and then
as I explained some diversity in taking
those risks you know maybe some new
technologies some old technologies to
drive forward once that happens then to
try
get clinical trials to drive forward as
quickly as possible now the delay here
is actually likely to be in
manufacturing because you know we might
want billions and billions of doses so
how do we then you know begin to invest
at risk in manufacturing plans if it's a
big company they may have adequate
manufacturing but you may want to work
with contract manufacturers other
companies or even build plants or use
new technologies modular technologies to
do this and then of course at the end is
going to be the process of getting the
vaccine out to all those who need it and
that's going to need to be depended upon
the risk at that time help me understand
this better self because right now it
feels like there's this huge effort
going on but companies are operating in
a way competitively with each other to
an extent countries are operating
competitively with each other are you
saying that what the world needs is is
some kind of widely supported global I
don't know vaccines are that that is
pulling together different efforts
coordinating encouraging everyone to
work together for the common good
and trying to get agreement on these big
decisions like what is the smart way
what are the smart few candidates to get
behind rather than this confusing
explosion and then how we ordinate
manufacturing etc like it's not is that
a person or a small organization that
the some combination of governments WH o
UN needs to put together so first of all
you want science to bubble up at the
beginning so you don't want to have
centralized control you know somebody's
saying I know best and I'm going to
predict this so you want it bubbling up
from all over the place but then you
want a coordinated effort the best the
group that is best placed to do that is
the World Health Organization
maintaining a list of all the different
programs that are going on we also have
other organizations I mentioned sepi
before sepi has now supported eight
different candidates I think it's going
to support more right now w-h-o has on
its list 44 candidates but some people
think as many as as double that so what
you want to do is say which are the most
likely to succeed and then put them
through some type of standardized that
of criteria to
a few of them to move forward
aggressively for the world obviously
science is going to keep moving they're
going to keep changing and it may be
that your original approach isn't right
and new what new ideas may come up but
you do need to have some process of
moving this forward and and really
that's what I called for and and what we
need to make sure is is that if
companies have adequate resources to do
this on their own that's fine but if not
they needed to be supported by the
public sector and again making sure
there's adequate manufacturing and
ultimately distribution then after a
period of time we can go back to normal
and return to the normal way vaccines
are are handled but I think that's
probably the best way to get there how
much my disgust and who should pay for
it well it depends how many cases there
are you know the good news is we're
talking now about trillions of dollars
in economic loss and this is going to be
a program that's going to be intends
well I mean I'm making the comparison
sorry you're absolutely right Chris I
mean we're talking about tens of
billions of dollars here not trillions
of dollars and and the reason that's
important is you want to make sure that
any good idea has its best chance of
moving forward and and we ought to we
ought to you know again optimized for
speed and not optimized for being cost
effective at this time so I guess you're
saying that like the rich countries may
well be able to afford some kind of
vaccine program I think what I hear you
doing here is representing a lot of the
countries that can't afford it and what
you're saying is that the world may have
to find a way of spending great tens of
billions dollars to avoid brilliance of
dollars of economic damage and all the
hardship that goes with it around the
world is that is that about right
that's absolutely right but I think the
important point is this needs to be a
global perspective I mean look at what
happened with Ebola we had a vaccine
that was originally made in Canada by
the public agency of Canada it was then
transferred to a US biotech then to a
merkin company which is obviously a
global player based in the US and
they're manufacturing it in Germany
that's the way science works and these
vaccines may need components from other
places so how do we
think about this in a global way and
make sure that by the way the second
vaccine that's in humans is from China
of course they've had a you know a lot
of time to work on it compared to some
others and you know they have a
candidate that's moving forward if that
candidate is successful we want to make
sure that's the one that's scaled up and
so you know for me it's making sure that
we're we're looking at this as a global
ecosystem with the best candidates
moving forward for the good of the world
lady we have a lot of people watching
from all over the world and in questions
especially from some of our friends in
India who are watching connected to this
just basically about how our coronation
is going to get access to this vaccine
and then specifically when we think
about who gets the vaccine first will
there be some sort of payment that where
people aren't paying for this vaccine
and those who can afford it
and get access before others well the
decision on who will pay for it will
ultimately come from the political
leaders and my recommendation would be
as you start off as a global public good
you make the vaccine available because
we're trying to stop the epidemic later
on we can add to your pricing in
different places but one of the concerns
of course is where is the epidemic going
to be at that point and who needs it
first now I would argue the people that
will need it first are probably health
workers because health workers are going
to be on the front lines and you want
them to be there to be able to take care
of people they're at risk of both
contracting it as well as spreading it
then you probably want to think about
the high risk you know individuals you
know the elderly people who have
pre-existing conditions and then
eventually the rest of the population if
it's needed so having some type of way
of thinking about that we're also need
to be thinking about equitable access
and that is going to mean thinking about
the entire world
now as Davi in the past including in
India has worked to make sure these new
technologies are there but you know
these are vaccines that existed and and
in this case it's a new vaccine we have
to make sure that it isn't hoarded only
in wealthy countries or in a select set
of countries and that one way to do that
would be to have vaccine production in
multiple places so today a lot of the
vaccine that Gavi uses are made around
the world some are made in in the United
States and your
but some are made in South Korea in
India in China in other countries and so
what we could do is have a vaccine
transfer the technology and
manufacturing in multiple different
sites so we can have enough vaccine for
that original launch but whatever
happens there will always be a period of
time when we'll have an exciting vaccine
and not enough doses to go around and
that's when we need to take hard
decisions based upon science on who
should get it thanks for that so cell
I'll be back later with other questions
thanks Whitney
thank you how confident are you that
will will eventually get one I mean we
still don't have a vaccine for HIV not
for the common cold how can you be
confident that we can get one this time
well first of all as you know I did a
TED talk
even before the one of 2015 talking
about HIV and flu and how new science
needs to come in and frankly we are
making progress against some of these
incredibly difficult organisms you know
you talked about variability that's the
problem with HIV it's constantly
changing and so you know you're chasing
that you know you get a good immune
response but it's to the strain that was
there before and now you're chasing new
strains there are ways to work around
that it's new science I actually I am
optimistic I'm optimistic because we
have some experience with SARS vaccines
and with Mayor's vaccines and so people
have worked on it they've been able to
get good immune responses in animals and
in people for those vaccines and so we
can build on that experience I mean I
can't tell you how long they'll last for
how effective they will be will they
need to have local mucosal immunity
which is in the mouth and nose as well
as serum immunity and in the bloodstream
will they need to have just antibodies
or the other arm of the immune system
the cellular arm these are questions
that need to be answered but I am a
great believer in the power of science
and I think in this case the organism is
not going to be quite as difficult as
the ones you're talking about that are
are much more difficult you mentioned in
TED talk five years ago said that we've
got this situation where we're spending
billions of dollars on nuclear
submarines in a patrol
in the oceans for a possible incoming
threat nuclear war threat or whatever
and and almost nothing on preparation
for a pandemic like the one we're
suffering if hope the world is
adequately shaken up by what's happening
now and gets rational about this well
what is the key sort of structural shift
that would be the pandemic equivalent of
having those those nuclear submarines
how do we prepare for a new virus that
we don't know what it will be or when it
will come how do we prepare to have a
much more rapid response well it's a
great question and I think the Ted
community has a role to play here so
first of all we need better surveillance
we need surveillance everywhere in the
world and that's why we don't want to
have another outbreak like in West
Africa with Ebola you want to have a
resilient health system in every country
that reaches out to the periphery and
that's an important priority we're doing
pretty good with immunization we reached
90% of the kids in the world with least
one dose of routine vaccine that's the
best of health interventions but we need
to reach that last 10% and put that
Health System in place then we need to
have a different view we need to start
working where are likely hotspots where
you know it's where we're cutting down
forests it's where in urban slums where
there's density of populations it's with
climate change and movement of different
vectors and what we need to do is use
predictive science and that's where big
data can help that's where AI can help
in terms of trying to do that and we
need to have a one health approach
because we tend to think of animal
diseases and by the way people have
worked on coronavirus vaccines for
animals because they also cause disease
there we need to make sure that the
scientists working on veterinary
vaccines are connected to humans are
thinking about this whole ecosystem and
we need to invest in that and and
unfortunately after an epidemic we have
all this everybody wants to invest and
they say whatever it takes and then they
just you know it we move on to other
things and investments go down what's
different about the military is that
there is a baseline of investment that
goes on all the time and nobody
questions that it contains
and and that level of preparedness needs
to be there Bill Gates and his talk and
in Ted when we did that back to back
said look you know the military are
doing wargames they're constantly
testing they have all this preparatory
activities why are we not doing that in
diseases and as you know since then
there has been some war games and
they've basically said we weren't
prepared and I think we're seeing now
that in fact we are not as prepared as
we could be so my hope the silver lining
would be that we prepare for the next
big outbreak because it's absolutely
evolutionarily certain we will continue
to have outbreaks the question is is how
prepared are we to deal with those as we
wait or a vaccine other other
interventions that could be made for
example you know the serum from people
who have been infected and have
recovered so that technique has been
used in other infectious diseases and
throughout history and even an Ebola
recently that's something that could
potentially be done of course today it's
more attractive if you can make
antibodies in the laboratory and then
have those available at scale and use
those and I know of a lot of companies
that are now working on producing those
antibodies which could be infused in in
an emergency situation and do that
obviously drugs may play an important
role here there's a similar effort to
try to create drugs that are active
against this organism and you know if we
knew that you get sick but there was an
effective treatment that would also
change a little bit of the dynamics of
the fear that exists around this
pandemic so I think there are lots of
interventions of course traditionally a
preventive vaccine is the best way to
deal with these types of epidemics so
paint us in an optimist in me begging
for something paint us the best case
scenario says lots of people are saying
I don't think we know we don't want to
be huddled in our homes by ourselves for
18 months lovely though the Internet is
what was what's what's the best-case
scenario putting all the pieces together
here well I mean I think what is likely
to happen but I don't want a
because we're in unprecedented times
here what's likely to happen is that
countries will who don't take this
seriously will have severe outbreaks
those that really take it seriously and
put these extraordinary mechanisms in
place will control the disease it'll
take some time it'll take you know this
is weeks maybe months not years to do
that and then you end up with a
situation where the disease is
controlled and you then can go back to
life as normal with some cautions around
it you know
now there's beginning to be new tests
that are going to be home tests we're
going to be able to you know figure out
whether classrooms regions countries
have disease we can go back to some
level of normalcy but one thing that's
really important is we can't have areas
of the world with raging disease so for
example if people said oh you know we're
not worried about Africa or only worried
about our countries you might end up a
situation where you have large numbers
of infections the virus is mutating it's
actually adapting to humans we saw some
of that with SARS and then it is easy to
reintroduce so what you've want to do is
damp it down everywhere in the world and
you know maybe it'll burn out maybe
that'll be it I personally think we'll
probably need a vaccine but you know
best-case scenario is that those alone
will stop the epidemic and what we'll
need is then a vaccine just in case it
comes back but of course if I was a
betting man I'd say let's get a vaccine
as soon as possible because that's the
way the best way to control a viral
infection particularly one that is
spread respiratory yeah it's so
interesting what you said there like the
vaccine doesn't know what continent it's
on what country it's in it just does
this thing so in terms of like people
listening here like what kind of
psychological advice can you give them
what should expectations be like do we
have to be ready to settle in for the
long haul here or should we be looking
forward to getting back to business
round about Easter time and celebrating
well again I don't want to put a
timeline on it like others do what
you're gonna want to see is that bending
of the curve you know I think bill
talked about this you want the reproduce
to rate below 1 you want to get it way
below 1 if you can and then to begin to
see the disease spread and what you
don't want to do is in the middle of
that jump out and start having parties
you know it's not time to go on spring
break and and and start mixing again but
with you know careful control you can
begin to release the controls if that's
what you know science shows us and I
think the most important thing is we
need the data to tell us that that's why
testing is so important with the wide
availability of testing we'll be able to
you know keep tabs know what's happening
we'll know how many people are
asymptomatic what's happened we'll know
you know where there are hot communities
and we'll be able to deal with this is
my prediction so I don't think this is
over a very very long time but I
wouldn't I wouldn't rush it
during this unprecedented moment
otherwise we're gonna end up seeing what
we saw in Italy or we're seeing in New
York right now is overwhelming of Elst
yeah no kidding New York is a scary
place right now
I was out walking today I hope that was
ok but there was no one there was no one
like you could like you couldn't get
within six feet of someone if you tried
right now that unlike the busiest walk
spots and I I mean that was nice to see
but man it's it's it's it's startling
and his recent data has shown that you
you know you can droplets can spread the
disease and so people are rightfully
being cautious and you know we didn't
know that you remember when we started
we said it's a point estimate out at
point outbreak out of lawn wet market
you had to be in the market to get the
disease then it was alright if you were
with sick people you've got the disease
then it was maybe asymptomatic
I think you know as we understand better
that gives us the tools to do the right
thing do you think there's a debate out
there that seems to be growing again
about masks like the East and West have
taken very different advice on masks
it's it's we're hearing from Gary Louie
yesterday that everyone in Hong Kong
China is basically wearing masks and
arguably that has been affected has the
advice in the West against not wearing
masks is that how much has that been
driven by just the fact that there's a
shortage of masks and that if anyone
needs to wear them it's medical
professionals I mean I could say if it's
water drop
it seems like musk would be effective in
preventing I mean the most the most
important intervention as you know is
some isolation and then very careful
hand washing or use of sanitizers and
because what happens is you touch your
face
I forget the number I think it's like
they know every one to two minutes and
you touch your eyes so if you reach a
door handle or you have contact with a
surface and we know the virus can live
on those surfaces and then you touch
your face touch your mouth
you know touch your nose you can spread
it so the purpose of a mask for person
who's not infected is not so much to
keep them from getting infected it is to
keep them from you know touching their
face and so I think what's interesting
here is you know how do we get people to
have this personal sanitation if we have
unlimited quantities of masks
people want to do it as a way to do you
know to remind themselves not to touch
their face now that's very different if
you're infected because if you're
coughing having a mask on does reduce
the spread of droplets and that's why
they recommend it you know in a in a
situation where somebody is infected and
has to go to the hospital has to go out
and and be seen
now let's touch with my faithful through
the Bill Gates interview apparently and
I got but called to task by online
friends which was which is very nice I
don't know if I've been doing that today
it's funny you unconscious of it it's
weird
well yes no it's a automatic and in fact
I I did a there was a whu-oh challenge
for safe hand-washing and I did a video
and I left my water running while I did
it Mike my friends in the developing
world came to me and said you know I
live in Switzerland where you know I'll
buy a lake where we have you know a lot
of water and I wasn't careful and they
were absolutely right so it's it's
really good we correct each other that's
an important point and help each other
in doing this to get us to as be as
compliant as we possibly can for these
issues with me yeah I mean I'm so
feedback online is overwhelmingly
positive
you're really answering all of
everyone's questions out there and
people really appreciate what you're
sharing stuff I think one big question
is just for folks who are watching from
home and maybe who are not part of
your community in terms of the science
community you know how can they
contribute to this global response
effort how can they do something advance
this that's that's a great question so
first of all I think it's really
important that citizens support leaders
who are following science are using
science and are you know because as you
know sometimes political leaders say
well I don't want to do this because you
know it's not good for my image or it's
not good for the economy it's not good
for whatever and I think you want to
have all of your decisions taken by
science understanding that not the best
science so citizens need to applaud even
if it's a tough decision that
politicians take for the good based upon
science that's a good thing the second
thing that really would be helpful is is
this concept how do we keep you know our
our world focused on the fact that you
know that these these epidemics will
occur um another example I didn't answer
which which Chris you know and when he
asked me about what could be done we
talked about this idea of platform
technologies these are vaccines that you
can test get them all ready and then
when a new organism occurs you could put
it in there and you know how to
manufacture how to scale it up these
types of things can be done sepia is
trying to do that now but the challenge
is if we a year after this go down to
having no money available for these
types of issues that will be a problem
so what you need is citizens to say I
understand now that you know health is
precious and I want my government you
know my leaders to invest in this and
the science in the ways of working so
that we will be as safe as we can be
going forward and I I think I can't
emphasize enough how important the
message that is for citizens everywhere
in the world hey let me stay stay on as
we wrap up here the I guess well what
I'd like to give you a chance to do
death as we as we wrap this up it's just
so like look at the camera and make make
your call to the world's leaders
companies and politicians scientist
citizens how how do we move forward
what's how would you wrap this up
so from my perspective what we need is
the world to come together at this
moment not to talk about you know our
national programs not to talk about our
science are the best and and they may be
the best but how do we as a world pool
our best science our best resources our
best ways of working our best
manufacturing our best clinical trials
to move this forward as fast as possible
the w-h-o is a global organization whose
job is this normative function and we
can you know get scientists to help them
make sure that that normative function
is as strong as it can be we can get the
leaders of the world to come together
and put the resources in place given the
cost it's having on the economy this
will be a real bargain to invest in it
but what we need is to have that mindset
of having science drive us and to make
sure that we have no barriers in
stopping that science going forward
that's my request to the world and I
think we can do it and if we do that we
will end up seeing the power of science
which will give us the tools we need to
either stop it hopefully it'll be
stopped by then but stop it and then
prepare us for the next one mm-hmm
confidence ed I have to say that it's
incredibly encouraging to know that
there are people like you out there in
the trenches but you know trying to
coordinate this immense and crucial
effort on behalf of all of us and also
that that there's an organization out
there that your organization is you know
has is tasked to carry any effective
vaccine to the many billions of people
who who may live in countries that can't
afford you know to pay the same prices
that the West can pay I mean that's
that's that's really cool that you're
doing that and thank you so much for
explaining so clearly to us what the
situation is I I guess I speak for the
majority people listening today all
power to you with with pulling these
threads together Thank You Seth thank
you sir thank you Chris and Whitney and
and the Ted community for all of your
support over the years and you know
let's continue
use science and technology for the good
of the world to solve problems like this
brilliant friend Branham well wonderful
I learned so much from this conversation
that seems like everyone online also
really did which was helpful and I'd
like to remind everyone that if you miss
part of this interview you can watch it
on our Facebook page as soon as we
finish and then also and I'm gonna read
the link it's go ted.com backslash Ted
connects so our Facebook page or go Ted
calm backsplash Ted connects thanks so
much for joining us we you know we get
the sense people literally won over the
world and in so many different
circumstances and yet you know where
this this moment is you know giving us a
new excuse to bring you all together
it's it's part of me even though I you
know you really could wish that we
weren't in this situation but it does
give us a chance to explore some ideas
in greater depth and we're normally able
to to have these conversations you know
these are not 15 minute talks on a red
circle they're you couldn't you could
just go a little bit deeper and there's
there's something really cool about that
that I think we want to do more of and
we want to figure out how to you know
how to hear from you and include you and
make sure that your questions and your
thoughts are coming in as we speak where
we're dreaming up what speakers to bring
next we know about Friday we don't
necessarily know beyond that but watch
this base when you talk about what's
gonna happen tomorrow so we're really
excited we're going to have Priya Parker
on about the week for us she is the
author of the art of gathering and she's
going to give us some really helpful
tips I think about how we can stay
connected during this time which is
something I'm sure all of us are are
struggling with as we're trying to
practice social distancing and you know
are just spending more time physically
apart so going into the weekend that
feels like the type of thing I think all
of us can really benefit from hearing if
you've if you've got value from this
conversation
consider sharing it sharing the link
those links with people you know that
would be cool and hang in there everyone
these are hard days we know many people
are struggling hugely hang in there
we'll get through it together somehow
and until tomorrow take care bye for now
take care everyone